- [Male] Who turned you into this guy?
Did something turn you--
- America and my mother.
I was born in the Soviet Union.
I didn't come up with much.
So adversity, America, my mom and my dad
because when I was 14 and started working
at my dad's liquor store
for two bucks an hour,
I was so full of shit
and he sucked it out of me over 10 years
'cause he hates lying and bullshit.
And so he scared me.
I was scared to embellish, let alone lie.
I don't get upset when people are like,
"Yo, this guy's full of shit,"
because I'm like, I understand.
I actually had that in me.
But my dad systematically took it out
and I think it comes
from lack of entitlement.
I turned 14
and by being the oldest
son in an immigrant family,
my dad dragged me into the small store
in Springfield, New Jersey,
Shopper's Discount Liquors.
I went from making $2,000 a weekend
looking cool to the
ladies with all my cash
to being paid two bucks an hour to bag ice
in my dad's liquor store
for 10 hours a day.
And more importantly,
I wasn't allowed to leave the basement.
I was truly like Sloth from Goonies.
I was like, "Hey, you guys."
Terrible, hated it.
Used to cry going to work for
the first year and a half.
Finally, when I was 16,
my dad let me leave the basement.
So I went upstairs to dust bottles
and in 1998, I took
over the family business
and from 1998 to 2005,
I grew the revenue of Wine Library
from a three to a $60
million a year business.
I had a burning desire
to pay back my parents
for being the best.
I was passionate,
like just obsessed with building
my family business for them
because they had put me on
so much, emotionally, not,
people are always saying,
when people like to razz me, they're like,
"Easy for you to say,
"you were given a liquor store."
I wasn't.
I built a business for my family
and left with no economics
because emotionally my
parents perfectly parented me
which is now been the
foundation of all my success.
There's only one way to
win a family business,
radical candor.
And you know how easy that
is in a family business?
Almost impossible.
So I'm giving you advice
that's hard, radical candor.
You're just gonna lose,
it's gonna eat you inside.
And I have good news for you.
This is the only chance
to have a good relationship with them,
not the other way around.
You think you're doing the right thing
to have a good relationship with them.
You're leading to the things
that's gonna make you have regrets
and real issues with them.
Then you're gonna snap
and you guys are gonna
have a bad relationship.
Second, third generation
family business people
pay the biggest tax in the world
and when they're fucking talented,
they really are fucked.
You know what family business
dynamics are good for?
Losers.
That's when you're lucky.
When you suck shit
and you're the one benefiting.
You know when family businesses suck?
When you're a winner.
And you're paying a tax
nobody's ever paid in life.
It wasn't about how
many impressions you got
or how many awards you
won in fucking Cannes.
It was about if we didn't
sell fucking pinot noir,
we weren't gonna eat.
So it was results driven.
My dad and I,
for all the things we agreed on,
all the things we disagreed on,
thank God we loved each other
just enough more than
we loved the business
which allowed us to keep a relationship.
But 99% of our energy was
always about the business
for the long term.
It's easy for everybody
from the outside saying,
"Yo bro, stop carrying
your sister and your uncle
"and everybody's getting
money off your back."
If it makes you feel good and you're okay
with 15 cents on the dollar
or 50 cents on the dollar,
well then that's your life.
So I would say this,
if you've got a problem with it
and your friends are saying that
because they're supporting
what you're saying after four beers,
that's one thing.
But if they're just
observing from the outside
and they're starting to change your mind,
I wouldn't let outside sources
tell you what to do with
inside of family dynamic.
At the end of the day,
if you are the parent in the
situation of a family business
or if you are the child
in the situation of a family business,
you have to deeply understand
that when both of you
are done and finished,
nobody's gonna count
how many zeroes they
have in the bank account,
they're gonna count how many
hearts and vibes and loves
are in the system.
What my dad and my brother
and I were capable of doing
was loving each other
just a little bit more
than the business making some more money
or the ego or insecurity
scratches that we needed
in the dynamic of our relationships.
If there's anything that this
film could get across to you
I hope it is that at the end
of the day on that last breath
ask yourself what you're gonna
be really thinking about.